well I I think life is pretty I don't
think it's so awful I mean I don't think
you should expect anything to go well I
think the only thing you have coming to
you after you're born the only thing you
have really coming to you is death
that's the only thing that's that you're
owed you're owed and the rest of it is
whether you get lucky enough to dodge
the buses that can hit you and stuff you
know I but I do I think the world the
way it is is pretty is is better than it
could be I think that you know there's
war and there's murder but there's not
as much as there could be there could be
so much more like when I see a crowd of
people like at Disneyland or something
I'm like how are they not killing each
other all the time like power they're
not like 50 murders every day at Disney
we're just people with knives it's gone
could just move you know when I hear
like a man was murdered I make sure he
was upset for his family but I was once
I saw a homeless guy at a bus stop and
he looked really wretched and there was
a woman next to him with a purse and in
my head I was saying to him you're
homeless life is kicking you in the
balls every day start murdering and
eating well like why would
that's very reasonable when you say it
in this week is testing week head
schools a lot about that so they're in
three days of extensive standardized
testing and do you what are the
consequences of the standardized testing
well the way I understand it if the
school's kids don't test well they burn
the school down so it's a pretty high
pressure lot of pressure on the kids
yeah Wow and the tests are written by
people that nobody knows who they are
it's very secretive and the questions
are cuz they prep to prepare for these
tests for a long time a lot of the year
is about the tests teaching for the time
teaching to the test they call it
because they they decided there's a new
way kids should think and we're gonna
prove they're thinking it by having him
pass these tests or we burn the school
down so anyway my kids kind of panic
when they're in these said you know
which is okay you know my mother was a
math teacher and she taught me that
moment where you go I don't know what
this is when you panic that means you're
about to figure it out ah
that means you've let go of what you
know and you're about to grab on to a
new thing that's great that you didn't
know yet so I always I'm there for them
in those moments and I go come on just
look at the problem and then I look at
the problems and it's like you know bill
has three goldfish
he buys two more how many dogs live in
London
crazy
you better notify the fire department
that's right New York is such a part of
your show and and and the way you depict
New York
you must go crazy for this town I do
because there's all sides of the
spectrum here you know sometimes your
with you I have children here too so
sometimes you're in a park and there's
pigeons and then there's an old lady
masturbating or whatever I'm saying this
that's one side of the spectrum yeah
the other you know how it is when you're
looking at pigeons yeah well she fed all
her bread to them and there was nothing
left so she started to masturbate for
them I'm doing it for the pigeons all
right I'm sorry part of it was I wanted
to cut out the middleman it's an
exciting idea I make a show I literally
out put it on my macbook and you watched
it on your iPad that was exciting to me
yeah sure but here's the thing when you
cut out the middleman you deal with the
customers directly are you really
dealing with the customer I don't I mean
I read some of the emails I get like one
guy wrote to me after I was on the air
for three weeks and he said I'm still on
the fence about trying your show I don't
know if I want to spend the five dollars
so can you write me an email try to
convince me to watch your show I'm like
you know take your five dollars and
shove it up your ass dancing is a
terrible career choice you like watching
it but you think it's a terrible career
worst available career choice
it's a massive amount of dedication
followed by giving up that's what FDA I
think because you know we're talking
there's like three dance jobs on the
planet earth and there's no second tier
like any other even a musician even
being a musician and on there what are
you doing don't be a musician that's a
stupid thing to do for a living what but
if it doesn't work out the way you want
it you can look at these you've got
these guys
no just to be clear what I'm saying well
these guys saying is that if you're a
dancer and you're the greatest dancer
ever nobody gives a [ __ ] first of all I
mean that because everybody dances and
then how many millionaire dancers are
there I don't you can dance if for like
two seconds at your peak you got to give
up you know I mean stripping you can
strip but you can you don't need to go
to Alvin Ailey to learn to do that yeah
that's a good career choice right being
a stripper and sometimes people ask me
for a pictures and I don't like doing it
what do I know well I know you're just
supposed to you supposed to go out well
you know the fans but I just go no I
don't want to do it yeah but once I like
so I always try to be nice how I say no
I go you know but thank you you know
okay so I was coming out of a restaurant
once and these two women are standing
there and I hear me say thank you
picture picture so I go I don't know I'm
sorry I I just don't like doing that I
hope that's okay and they're like
they're like okay I said what's your
name though and she's like Janet hye-jin
and I'm Louie hi
thank guys I'm sorry to thank you and
then I walk away and I see the two women
give their camera to some guy to take
their picture yeah
[Applause]
this story from their point of view
they're asked I want a picture of
themselves and they go to the random
stranger would you like oh you know I
just don't like doing it all your fault
sure yeah but I was watching Schindler's
List in this moment happened that just
stuck with me it's a scene where that
all the Jews are being thrown out of
Warsaw and that's very super sad and
they were going down the street and
there's these Polish people that aren't
Jewish watching them leave and one of
them is a little girl and she's about 7
years old and she's on a mailbox and
she's very cute and she's yelling
goodbye Jews goodbye Jews and this
really left an impression on me and
probably on the Jews that she was
yelling at too because I think it's real
I think very powerful moment yes and I
think it probably really happened and
somebody told Spielberg about that and
he was like we're doing that in the
movie so he made that scene which means
he had to find a little girl to play
that little girl he had to find a little
cute girl who could yell goodbye Joe's
at grownups right and that's a really
and I know how movies are made so I know
somewhere there's a tape of like 50
little girls
trying to get the goodbye Jews part and
they're all adorable March so good at it
there's no kid actors that are like you
know Sean Penn can die work from within
they're all adorable does it tape
somewhere of little girls hi my name is
anne-marie and I'm with William Morris
goodbye Jews goodbye Jews Emory we need
a little more anger oh I'm sorry
goodbye June okay next
and there's another girl okay next and
then comes the girl who's amazing and
her mother has prepared her for months
she knows how to walk in the room hi my
name is Louise and I am really happy to
meet you The Sun will come out tomorrow
bet your we just need the line actually
oh I'm sorry
goodbye
and there's a new thing the cloud they
want you to go to the cloud and they are
selling it is a great idea
just you don't need your stuff just give
it to us we'll keep it on the cloud it's
fine you don't have to and you're like
really put those are my pictures and my
just give we'll keep it on the cloud you
pay a little rent to have it up on the
cloud and the way they're gonna talk you
into this is that you get to have a
smaller device because you don't need to
keep this stuff on it you don't say
that's right okay like this somebody
gave me this iPhone this is where knife
phone is right now okay now it's gonna
when they when they tell you you want to
keep another cloud they're gonna say
this is this is the iPhone now the off
the next iPhone is it's just gonna be
this and it's just gonna be this thing
because you need this to store all your
movies and stuff but you're just gonna
have this and you just rubbing oh oh I
want to see Tom Cruise analogous Tom
Cruise will be all around your face and
then you want to see you know some Hayek
and then you take it and parents really
struggle with like all the other kids
have the father terrible thing so my kid
has to yeah let's let you know let your
kid go and be a better example to the
kids they do this just cuz the other
stupid kids have phones doesn't mean
that okay well my kid has to be stupid
otherwise she'll feel weird right you
know I think these things are toxic I
don't especially for kids it's just this
thing it's bad and yeah they don't look
at people when they talk to them and
they don't build the empathy you know
kids are mean and it's cuz they're
trying it out they they look at a kid
they go you're fat and then they see the
kids face scrunch up and they go ooh
that doesn't feel good to make a person
do that but they got to start with doing
the mean thing but when they write your
fat then they just go mmm that was fun I
like
let me ask you a question
and this specifically about breakfast I
have this conversation with my son who
was 10 who is I guess right between the
ages your daughters and it goes like
this well what would you like for
breakfast I'm not hungry
well yeah but let's just say you were
what how about bacon no how about eggs
no pancakes no and so we go through
every imaginable form of consumable
human right yeah none of which interests
the kid and then so now we go back and
we start over and it's clear that he has
decided on his side he's gonna say no to
everything I come up with but yet they
have to eat yes they do boy what do you
do why are you asking him what he wants
I mean you're you're asking her on the
side where everything's headed and look
I know why you're asking I get it but
the thing is you're saying if he doesn't
decide what he wants he won't eat I'm
already 8-ball that's never gonna be his
oh yeah with your girls you just put the
food in front here's what we're having
is what I don't want that and I go all
right what do you want them
well how are your children doing are
they alright
how are they my kids are good yeah I
mean they can't on paper they're great
they're two little white girls in
America right sometimes I look at it
that way I look at him I'm like you
can't say anything yeah you're you're
doing awesome right just boilerplate
great lives I gave my daughter medicine
the other day knows bubblegum flavored
so that she'll take it bubble gum
flavored medicine yeah you get me like
tylenol it's bubblegum flavor oh it's
not methadone or anything no no I
guarantee she's got a fever tylenol
bubblegum flavor in she goes ill I'm
like you
[Applause]
medicine medicine right is that medicine
most children don't have medicine
chilling in the world they get sick they
die on a rock with a bear eating them
that's how they handle it he's got a
sniff will ring the bear bell and put
them outside you're a little white girl
in a more clothes made by children your
age professionally about your bubblegum
medicine you got the holidays coming up
are you doing any any plans any swing
like a very holiday guy yeah I just want
to say I'm not trying to say that if
you're white you can't complain right
I'm just saying that if you're black you
get to complain more right right because
you don't tell the band that
you feel that we now in the 21st century
we take technology for grant well yeah
because now we live in an in an amazing
amazing world and it's wasted on the on
the crappiest generation of just spoiled
idiots that don't care because this is
what people are like now they got their
phone really oh it won't give it a
second it's going to space can you give
it a second to get back from space I was
on an airplane and there was internet
high-speed Internet on the airplane
that's the newest thing that I know
exists and I'm sitting on the plane and
they go open up your laptop you can go
on the internet and it's fast and I'm
watching YouTube clips it's in an
airplane and then it breaks down and
they apologize the Internet's not
working the guy next to me goes boom
like how quickly the world owes him
something yes he knew existed only 10
seconds ago I know you know and I know
you've told your kids
honesty is its own reward
I don't think so here's the thing about
to me about lying is that I don't think
you should do it but I get it mm-hmm
that's how I feel but I get it right
because kids lie because they're in
trouble you know if you're in trouble as
a kid it's too much as you can't take it
yeah kids don't lie for some weird
Machiavellian you know they're not like
you know my teacher said about you it's
interesting you know they don't they're
not trying to start something it's
because somebody who's like did you take
that chocolate and they're terrified
yeah
terrifying if you're in trouble you
don't care you're growing up you just go
oh sorry right well again
again I've been in trouble and that
didn't work sorry sorry